so instead sighing were joined by noah
rothman he's an associate editor
commentary magazine he called us Russian
propagandists in ostensibly patriotic
too but at least he's brave enough to
come and explain himself
no Rothman joins us tonight Noah thanks
for coming on my pleasure thanks for
having me so we have legitimate kind of
news on this story this comes from
Reuters the defense secretary was just
asked specifically the question
essentially we asked on Monday the one
that you call this traitors for asking
which is do we know that Assad was
behind the gas attack and this is what
the secretary defense just said quote
we're still assessing the intelligence
ourselves and our allies we're still
working on this so as with the gas
attack last year last April the
Secretary of Defense who would know has
not confirmed that we know the Assad
government did it so why am i
unpatriotic for asking the same question
well let me say at the outset I have not
called you a traitor I did not call you
on patriotic I have you see you called
me and I'm quoting an ostensibly a
patriotic American opinion maker who is
advancing the geopolitical narratives in
defense of a blood-soaked regime that
threatens American interests I'm not
attacking you you were attacking me for
asking the most basic of all questions
and it turns out that the Secretary of
Defense well I believe has less say this
should be answered but whether you know
it or not you are advancing pro-assad
narratives and you should check out Iran
TV press TV and the Kremlin funded
Network RT to see the favorable coverage
you are receiving I don't believe you're
doing that's irrelevant to the question
I don't I don't seek that coverage the
Secretary of Defense has been asked
twice directly on this and in neither
case did he in contrast to propagandists
like yourself say unequivocally we know
the Assad government did this this is
not an ancillary question this essential
question sites to the opposite in fact
his comments he made it very clear that
he is not questioning the outcome of
investigations like that conducted by
the organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons or the United Nations
joint investigative mechanism which went
so far as to say not only do we define
this to be Syria sarin in 2017 but Syria
was responsible for it these are these
are investigations that were conducted
very if I can just read and and I have
to say I mean I again I don't want to be
mean to you and I know you're new to
this but here's part of the Q&A with
the Secretary of Defense on the previous
gas attack and he's asked is there
credible evidence about sarin and
chlorine no I have not got that evidence
not specifically I don't have the
evidence what I'm saying is that other
groups on the out on the ground NGOs
fighters have said sarin has been used
we are looking for evidence I don't have
evidence credible or uncredible that was
the response from the actual exchange I
don't know jeez he an agent of Putin too
for saying that I don't know why you
would suggest that he is saying that we
don't have assets on the ground in
western Syria which is frankly the truth
those who have been on the ground in
western Syria again the OSI the CW and
the United Nations have established
rather definitively that this 2017
attack was a sarin attack now this crap
most recent attack there hasn't been a
comprehensive report which is gostop
know but nobody is contesting the nature
of the attack that's immaterial we can
determine what the chemical was the
question is who launched it because
that's the question on which our action
turns or if it was launched by rebel
groups then we probably wouldn't attack
the Syrian army in response so who did
it is the question and and the US
government has not definitively
determined that that's all I said on
Monday and you accused me of defending a
blunt way you said actually is that this
was a propaganda designed to manipulate
the American public opinion essentially
questioning the Trump administration
suggesting that they are they have
misled the public into why and that is
very one hold on I'm questioning anyone
who states this fact what he doesn't
know as fact that's it
it is propaganda to say something that
you don't know is true and pretend we
don't know that the rebels do not have
an air force we know that these were
delivered by air we know that they
contain can't they're delivered by
canisters there have been appearing a
variety of different places which is
compression which is what you need to
use a precursor for sarin nerve gas and
those are information that is delivered
to us by people on the ground we do not
have American assets in western Syria so
what do you say other people these are
people with skin in the game in the
Civil War currently unfolding and look I
am NOT here to defend and I hardly hat
would have to say this with a rational
person the regime of Assad
why would I I'm an American my aunt
is only in what's best for America and
we should establish what they do exactly
and that's why actors like you and on
many other channels and all over the
left you're hearing people say what you
said which is it's unpatriotic or in
fact treasonous in effect to ask these
questions and I'm just saying how do you
account for the fact that the Secretary
of State is saying the same thing I said
on Monday do you think he's disloyal I
mean that's a real question based on the
columns you've written no I say and I
will repeat the you are
mischaracterizing his remarks he is not
calling into question the evidence that
has been put supplied to the United
Nations investigators in the OCW but if
you do want to get into why it is
necessary to respond to these attacks in
the American interest and not in some
vague notions of morality then we should
talk about that because I do agree that
the American public has not been
informed by the political class as to
what American interests are at stake and
please don't speak of the political
classes if you stand outside it you are
clearly acting as a tool on behalf of
people who want the u.s. to proceed with
war and maybe we should and I keep an
open mind because I don't know but I do
know lying when I see it and you've
engaged in a lot of others have -
pretending you know what you don't know
so now you tell me why it's an America's
interest to wage war in Syria two points
number one the United States has troops
all around the world chemical weapons
are relatively ubiquitous and pretty
cheap when Americans come into contact
even casual contact with these as they
did in Iraq it can affect you for the
rest of your life we do not want to see
a future in which chemical warfare has
become a status quo of the battlefield
because the United States will come into
contact with it and American soldiers
will suffer from it secondarily in the
last 14 months there have been two
state-sponsored terrorist attacks on
foreign soil Russia and North Korea
respectively using weapons of mass
destruction using chemical nerve agents
this is a very dangerous new reality and
we need to stop it now and re-establish
the Traymore but of course you're
arguing parallel to the real argument
which is how do we respond and who did
this and so we know that rebel groups
have in their possession there's video
of it since we all trust video now of
them in possession of chemical weapons
so really if you seek to deter the use
of chemical weapons in the future you'd
want to punish the people who use them
this time and as we stated at the outset
and you agreed we're not sure so why are
we also an I didn't say that actually
taking your premise that face value
some UN reports that suggest in 2013
that rebel groups Islamist groups to get
their hands on chemical weapons as a
result of the implosion of the Syrian
state and a lesson there is to prevent
the implosion of a state that has
chemical weapons if you were to if you
were to nip this in the bud as it were
then you would want to make sure you
introduce any future possibilities in
which rebel groups that we know reliable
can get their hands on these weapons
right they're not reliable which is why
I don't want them in charge of Syria
which is why I'm not calling for a war
with Syria in contrast to you but can we
end we're out of time on this one point
which is if you want to have an adult
conversation about adult issues don't
wouldn't you agree that it's helpful not
to call names but to engage with the
actual questions it's not call your
names and I did not dismiss you I
answered your questions directly self
awareness not your strong suit but I
appreciate your coming on tonight thank
you thank you for having me Nigel frosh
is the former head of the UK
Independence Party he helped lead the
brexit campaign he's been a longtime
pretty famous supporter of President
Trump one of the very few on the island
in which he lives he joins us tonight
Nigel thanks for coming on as a
supporter what do you what do you make
of the move toward engagement war with
Syria well just think about what's
happened over the course of the last 15
years or so Iraq we went in we tried to
get rid of the Arab nationalist dictator
we succeeded what was the result
hundreds of thousands of death and chaos
Libya the same we go in we get rid of an
Arab nationalist leader that we don't
like and we open the door for Isis and
of course the crisis we've seen coming
over the Mediterranean to Europe so our
track record our track record of
intervening because morally we think we
should without a proper strategy without
working out a long-term plan is bad and
let's just look at this a week ago the
president said American troops would
pull out of Syria tonight we appear to
be on the verge of perhaps quite
large-scale military action and not just
with America France and Britain joining
- do we have a plan can you imagine if
the scale of the strikes was such that a
sad got toppled do we actually think
that would make Syria safer and better
you know whatever we think whatever we
think
sad I'm a support that he's had from the
Russians they have just beaten Isis
militarily in the field so there are
some big issues here where we have
similar interests and yet the advocates
for this are telling us that somehow
Assad which has been his government has
been at war with Sunni extremists for
years was somehow in league with Isis so
raises a larger question why all the
lying what what is this really about I'm
honestly confused I but I know lying
when I see it and it's going on now in a
large scale yeah I understand that
but I'm also curious too as to why
Donald Trump who was so clear in 2013 as
indeed I was as to why it was not a good
idea to get involved in Syria it was not
a good idea to arm the rebels quite why
Donald Trump appears have had this
change of mind I don't know it's seen
for some time that the globalists in the
West need to have an enemy and yet kind
of want to have a war and you know going
to war is the most serious decision any
government could ever take this should
not be done without clear strategy and
I'll give a warning a warning to all the
politicians here in Britain and many of
those in America you and your chums in
your clubs tonight may think this is the
right thing to do be very careful and
very cautious about public opinion a
poll out in Britain today shows only one
in four Britons supports military action
and I'll bet in America it's not a
majority either but if you don't believe
in democracy it doesn't really matter
last question quickly do you think that
one of the purposes of war would be to
divert attention from the fact that
you're not taking care of your own
people you're elected to look after your
own people and when you don't maybe
having a war as a way to change the
conversation yes it is it's also a great
deflection away from all sorts of social
issues you know which really give all of
our problems great countries the first
role of government is to protect and
maintain the interests of its citizens
however horrible things in Syria are
they did not affect directly American
interests or British interests either
and I hope our leaders think again
I hope so too you know so far thank you
for that for that
your explanation